the force is broadening its horizons in  the form of a new deal with Turner the  time warner division has inked a  nine-figure deal with Disney for the  cable rights to 10 of the franchise  films the deal lasts through 2022 and  cost Turner over 250 million dollars  that sounds like a still since the force  awakens alone made 2 billion dollars  worldwide in the box office it's  important to point out that the first of  these movies will not be available until  2018 on basic cable after they conclude  a year-long run on netflix and disney  still holds the rights to sell the new  movies to broadcast TV either way this  is great for fans and opens the door for  us to watch new Star Wars movies like we  want right after an episode of Pawn  Stars without even having to change the  channel